hé Lily content de te voir toi aussi Kim
va bien comment les choses comme l'habituelle
Kim chérie chérie reculent maintenant je peux le
faire tes mains maintenant
21 il rejoint l'armée 23 il rejoint les
forces spéciales il est un tireur d'élite formé un
expert en explosifs pas de service  l'enregistrement va
décharger n'enregistrer rien ce gars
ici il sait hors de la sphère était
soigneusement Kim quelque chose de terrible est
arrivé à ta mère papa c'était Klingon
ne fais confiance à personne il y a des choses que j'ai
faites dans ma vie et j'étais toujours prêt
à affronter  les conséquences pour protéger ma
famille
que savez-vous ce que je sais c'est que bientôt
tous ceux que vous aimez seront morts quelle est
votre première priorité ici inspecteur mon
travail est de vous amener ma première priorité
est de protéger le seul qui me reste
qu'est-ce que vous allez  à faire je vais
finir ça si tu prends cette route
LAPD le FBI CIA
tu vas tous venir pour toi ils te
trouveront
et tu t'arrêteras
bonne chance
[Musique]